let's jump into this first story talking
about communist cuba is where
it's getting dark man daily mail reports
quote the communists have lost
control first cuban demonstrator is
killed after police
quote opened fire on peaceful protest
while anti-government reporter is
arrested live on tv
as unrest continues dubis laurencio
tajeda 36 died monday in a suburb of
havana
during a clash between protesters and
police witnesses claimed security forces
had responded to demonstrators with
gunfire
after they threw rocks social media
activist dina stars was arrested
live on tv by cuban security forces on
tuesday
cuban government launched crackdown on
protest after large-scale demonstrations
drafted on sunday
seems to be getting worse man i don't
know you seem to know a lot about
communists though jack
what's happening in cuba yeah so um you
know i i
funny enough is i always joke about this
so i spent almost a year
right in cuba when i was at guantanamo
but
because when i was there under the obama
administration we didn't have status
forces agreement we still don't have a
status force agreement between the us
and cuba
in terms of that so we were not allowed
actually out into the island right
so we used to have these t-shirts that
we would sell on base that said
uh you're here in cuba close but no
cigar
[Music]
and um and so i've always kind of wanted
to actually visit the rest of the island
but i got really into
uh just how cuba works when i was there
studying it because
uh needless to say let's just say that
you know well i was there for
uh the detainee operations we also had
people who were there from an intel side
that were not
paying attention to them they were
paying attention to the broader you know
cuba the landscape there the military
the politics
and and of course we actually had some
communication with them we would say
across the fence
uh just in terms of hey if there's you
know uh because it's very arid there on
that part of cuba because the mountains
so you know wildfires is a big issue
just like in california so
that's something obviously would affect
both sides so it just makes sense to
kind of have a monthly meeting where we
sit down and talk
yeah and you would so what you're seeing
now basically
is look the castros are essentially over
right raul castro has you know he's on
his last legs he's kind of cut ties
he abdicated the throne right he's gone
he's gone and so
they know that this that the new
leadership who by the way who is still
on twitter
verified and able to tweet yep right
throughout
everything you just said everything you
know cracking down on protesters
shooting pro killing them uh arresting
journalists
in the middle of the street he is
allowed to tweet but donald trump of
course is banned who is it
this is the cuban leader you're saying
the leader yeah what's the right what's
his name
who is it what's his i forgot his name
man let's find out
the man of the hour you said the status
of force agreement jack is that
something that the government will
officially do with another government
when they are going to have military
that is going to be out and about
right so right so you need some kind of
legal uh
you need essentially a legal purpose for
being there so uh you look at a country
where
the u.s has overseas bases uh on a more
normal
with a country where we have more
normalized relations so talk about south
korea germany japan those are kind of
like the three
big ones also uh uk we have we have some
people there and on a few bases
um and so you would have an essential
agreement where okay we are not
immigrating we don't need visas right we
don't need
any specific um documentation other than
the orders right and that's all covered
under that status of forces agreement so
um you know of course and you know the
sort of cynical view of that is like
this is u.s imperialism right why does
the u.s need these all of these bases
around the world
why are they providing this blanket of
of international
security this is the way that russia
would describe it this is the way that
china certainly describes it especially
when it comes to uh
east asia and that's fear but this is
that's the basic idea that status of
force agreement and you'll also see this
in terms of like
you know if you're going over somewhere
for a uh you know an exercise like we do
exercises with
with tons of of of militaries and so the
idea or tons of countries around the
world thailand
australia etc and so the idea is that
you wouldn't necessarily need a visa to
go because you're going on orders going
on mission
is it the end of the world we got we got
china china war planes in taiwan we got
south africa's collapsing
you got the revolt in cuba then you've
got in the u.s haiti haiti as well i
mean
it's assassinated yeah it's like we we
actually kind of drove past that it's
like
the president of haiti is assassinated
and everyone just kind of says uh you
know it's haiti
well well actually no what happened was
the president of haiti gets assassinated
and everyone's like whoa
what's happening and then all of a
sudden everyone turns because south
africa lights up cuba lights up
so look man fourth turning it might not
be a world war what if it's a global
economic collapse
miguel
what you're seeing now is by the way it
this
is a reformation of the global order
right this is a reformation because
uh for a variety of reasons america
which as
you know as i delineated before which
had maintained that system and you can
see the military power but also the
economic power
and the cultural power of the united
states all of those
have become diminished over the past
decade and really over the past couple
years
now uh in in the trump years you know
there was this sort of like sudden
resurgence people are saying hey is the
u.s going to go back to that position
but then that you know that that was
basically usurped by biden and so that
that path seems to be closed and now
people are realizing
they are going back into what the status
quo pro-ante was
prior to trump which will and the phrase
i'm going to say and you'll all remember
it
this was managed decline right we were
told this again
and again throughout the obama years the
u.s is headed toward a managed decline
and we were told you
were they used all these technocratic
phrases to sort of explain well this is
just the way
you know things are going and countries
you know they they rise and they fall
and this is
this is normal and you know i believe in
american exceptionalism the same way
greeks believe in greek exceptionalism
etc etc that was the quote
famous quote from barack obama so this
is the idea and i want people to
understand
that this is being done by policy this
is being
done by decisions right human decisions
human agency that's made
on behalf of the people in power that
have made this decision they've made the
decision to
outsource right u.s jobs which is
outsourcing our manufacturing base which
is outsourcing our wealth
all of the secondary and tertiary
industries and businesses and
communities that would have thrived off
that i was actually just up in
in maine we went up for the fourth of
july and
you know it's it's great because you can
go on the coast and there's all these
sort of like old money cities and old
money like beach towns
and you go 30 minutes away and it's all
uh this post-industrial
just bleak societies where you know
former factory towns with the factories
gone
and the the workers the families the
workers are all still there wondering
hey
what what do we do now right we're still
here and
you know we we'd like to stay in our
towns but we're just stuck
it's all it's all done through that's
the interesting thing about policy
you can you can be an industrialist you
can run a factory and through no
like no fault of your own the government
decides they're going to put pressure on
your business that forces it
to leave the country so of course it
still comes down to the conscious
decisions of a lot of these you know
people who run these companies
but when they say something like we're
going to increase the minimum wage
we're going to increase the corporate
tax then we're going to do a free trade
agreement for factories outside
yep it's impossible to compete let's say
you make
uh ian you gave me this little was it
obsidian that is obsidian is volcanic
glass this is obsidian yeah wow that's
that and how do they they file it to
this
they polish it but let's say you you
have a you have an obsidian factor in
you make these fancy little obsidians
we're talking all right and you operate
in uh
hawaii new jersey okay new jersey and
then they announced
volcanic new jersey yeah well they
import all the volcanic rocks
naturally so they they announced they're
going to be raising the minimum wage
raising the corporate taxes and at the
same time free trade agreements with
manufacturing companies
too much for my company and you say you
know what
my workers deserve fifteen dollars an
hour i do so
i gladly accept the cost increase and i
should pay my fair share in taxes
all right so you go over the numbers you
say to pay everyone 15 an hour and pay a
20
tax we're gonna have to charge five
dollars for every
beautiful obsidian stone no problem
right then all of a sudden you go to
walmart and there's
china stone for three dollars and you
say there's literally no
way we can make the obsidian stones for
three dollars
well china has slaves and they can
import these products for free with no
charge
so your company goes out of business
because it's impossible to compete with
the free
the slave labor trying to use it and
understand right this
was the idea this was actually the plan
all the way back before when and and
funny enough right
prior to occupy wall street what was the
big you know i talked about antifa light
wrote the whole book about antifa
um what was the big sort of antifa
moment
right it was the battle of seattle 1999
wto and the wto
and it was all about who getting into
the wto it was all about
china getting into the wto over slave
labor and that was
antifa right protesting against
china and violently very violently
rioting those were trying to get into
wtf those were gen xers
so a big thing at play here is gen x was
protesting at the battle in seattle in
99. and they were flying tibetan flags
that was second wave antennae
yeah exactly i wouldn't call them antifa
they were they were
anti-free trade like it was it was it
was it was more classically liberal out
of ways but they were leftists
and then 10 years goes by and you get a
little bit more than 10 years 12 years
you get occupy wall street what's that
millennials with some gen xers who were
at the wto but many of those gen xers
the wta moved on had families got jobs
and they're gone
now the millennials come in it's been
ten years
since occupy wall street ten years not
crazy it'll be ten years in two months
nine nine uh september 17th 2011. park
that was nice now it's gen z people who
are 10 years old during occupy
have no idea what it was about are now
in their 20s entering their 20s
and they're voting for people and they
know nothing about the obama
administration
that's why i talk about the federal
reserve like a chicken with my head cut
off on this show because we got to teach
these people about
what is what is at least part of the
root cause of social disorder right now
and it's i think it's the
the privatization of our monetary supply
bro look
jack talks about the plan the wto in 99.
again
this is because it all goes back to it
man so but but it's
it's as i explained how you think that
joe biden doesn't know what he's doing
he's called for those three things
specifically we're going to raise
the minimum wage and we're going to
increase corporate tax so they pay their
fair share and then
free trade agreements and you wonder why
all those things come together
it's to make sure you can't run your
business now here's the thing
these people who were 10 years old
during occupy wall street weren't even
alive during the battle in seattle
during the wto stuff right
now they don't know any of this now all
they know is they're growing up and the
system is broken and the government
should give them free stuff
and when you try to explain to them dude
it's biden he's been doing this for 50
years they go
shut up fascist did you see that they're
going to be giving
families 300 per kid yes for until their
age
tax credit this is how we afford this
how many we can't
so they're just going to print more
money bro have you seen the consumer
price index
what was the percentage it said it's
like five point something it's going up
right
gas is up 45 percent it's insane
by inflation bind inflation inflation
we're gonna we're gonna it's it's
it's you know they they call what do
they call it uh uh massive monetary
theory
and modern monetization modern
biotherapy theory modern monetary theory
but it's not modern monetary theory
anymore now it's modern monetary
practice
right it's we can spend forever we can
spend indefinitely
we can and when you hear the fed say oh
we're gonna we're adding to our balance
sheet we're adding to the fed balance
sheet right
right well that means you are taking on
debt which means when you're taking on
the debt you're issuing what you're
you're issuing loans
to banks at the highest level right the
reason that they are doing this
is because they want all of you they
want millennials they want gen z
to become a renter class right you right
they
want you you'll own nothing they you'll
live in the pod you'll eat the bugs
right you will own nothing and you'll be
happy right
that doesn't mean that no one owns
everything right
someone is going to own something
someone and that someone as we're
finding out now
is going to be wall street that's going
to be blackrock it's going to be
blackstone it's going to be these
massive companies
that are coming in now and purchasing
what real estate so your landlord
right let's you know we know how much
antifa love communism right yeah exactly
so you have corpianism where these
corporations
from wall street are now controlling the
land they're controlling your real
estate they're
if you want to go out and so and this is
the amazing part of it because rent's
just going to go up
and so who's paying for those loans the
renter is
you are you are going to be a russian
serf
look how brilliant the whole college
plan was
everybody must go to college two things
happen when they went to college
they took on massive debt they can't pay
back and they can't declare bankruptcy
on
and they got indoctrinated with
psychotic you know cult bs
they told everybody to take it on at the
very least if they don't indoctrinate
you they make you an indentured servant
now they're buying up all the houses so
if you want to live somewhere
they're going to say but you got to pay
us rent hey we're a private company
if you want to live in my house you got
to pay the rent and then when you give
them problems they'll say we're raising
your rent
oh no and you get kicked out it is so
where are you going to go
how are you going to how are you going
to have any type of wealth formation if
you don't have wealth formation
how are you going to support a family
god forbid and if you do
somehow manage to be able to get married
to have a couple of kids
how are you even going to be able to
generate enough wealth to pass something
on to them
so you create into something the left i
used to talk about all the time
generational wealth right dude you're
not going to be able to do that with the
negative interest rates the way they are
now this is
all done by design and the manufacturing
where does it go it goes to asia why
because they don't have our labor laws
you have you have slaves essentially
slave labor in china in xinjiang with
the uyghurs
that are building all this stuff so they
don't have to worry about them they're
not getting the wealth the wealth is
going into the one percent of china and
who is that that's the ccp and this is
gets back to my earlier point before
when when we talked about the battle of
seattle when when people were talking
about putting
uh and this was this was clinton right
this was clinton putting
china into the wto and then later bush
41 bush 43 bush 41 talked about this of
course the response to
tiananmen square he said well we just
need to bring china into the global
order
that was what was said again and again
and again people were saying tiananmen
square
they're crushing students the same way
that people are being crushed the
protesters in cuba right now
bring them into the global order bring
them into the global order
and they'll become more open they'll
become more socially liberal they'll
become more transparent
no it was the exact opposite that
happened but
i think we became more authoritarian but
i i think we are always more
authoritarian
i think you just can't do it instantly
so look at what's happening now with
what joe biden's saying about
civil war stuff i mean the way he's
describing people on
on one six the insurrectionists the
confederates never breached our capital
come on man
and then you hear what he talks about
the the the fbi saying extension your
neighbors
you you we're hearing that joe biden
wouldn't have to so
there's there's that refrain too that i
believe people will say that
you know if if the situation were
hopeless the propaganda would be
unnecessary
joe biden's not going to philadelphia
not going to
you know where i'm where i'm from and
giving a massive speech
standing across the constitution centers
down across independence mall from
in the actual site of the signing of
declaration in the constitution
he's not going to give a speech like
that from a position of strength
that was done from a position of
weakness that's because
the contradictions are accelerating too
fast right now the hegelian dialectic
which the left used to move forward they
used to progress with
is happening too fast and not enough
people
are able to keep up with it that's why
they realize that their critical mass is
falling apart
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you